hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
something that i really don't care about
like at all i'm not even kidding however
i think my audience would like it and
it's it's entertaining so i will comment
on it
i am reacting how drake stole
some random model from
some random dude that i don't know
okay so if you guys haven't seen which
i'm sure you've seen like some stuff
already
uh this is the model obviously she's
beautiful
um that's drake or is she a rapper oh
singer sorry she looks like a model
and that was her old fiance obviously
she has a type
um so i was like looking for
the i guess
like she was supposed to be on like a
song with drake
and this guy
put on instagram that when she went to
be on the song with him
that she cheated so let's see imagine
having the most beautiful supportive and
faithful relationship
eight years long with an engagement and
wedding planned
a beautiful woman on your side as your
ride or die then this major opportunity
comes
and a world star calls your fiance to
sign a record deal flies you both over
and then out of nowhere all trusted
advantage
vanished with knives in your back in
your heart
imagine but also imagine the power of
the universe
sending love and greatness to me in an
astro
astronomical and spiritual way
and then it says something under it says
i'm no longer with this person
people think i'm together with i'm no
longer with the eight years that i
thought i'm together with i'm no longer
with the engagement i thought i
was together with i am no longer with
the broken trust
i was brought together with i was no
longer in the pain
i thought i was together with i am now
with the acceptance i want to be
together with i am now with the healing
i want to be together with
i am now with the most beautiful and
powerful light in the stars
i am now with the conspiring of
greatness
things the universe wants me to be
together with
and this is like a picture of her
okay what do i think
one i don't really care but like this
woman
like to be honest fumbled a bag if
assuming her fiance was good to her you
never know what happens behind
closed doors like let's just say he was
a good
boyfriend everything you're just gonna
be a notch on drake's belt you know how
many girls he's like hooked up with
like literally so many like and so you
had a guy that actually like treasured
you
valued you like seems like a good guy
seems like he's got
good career or whatever maybe he wasn't
maybe that was why she did it i don't
know
um but she fumbled the bag like
honestly and i doubt
if her and drake start dating even let's
let's say drake dates her okay let's say
drake dates this girl
how long are they gonna date how long do
his relationships
really last and would drake be faithful
to her
i don't know i don't think that's worth
it but
girls will chase clout i guess
i mean she's stunning i'll give her that
um
and i guess i can't find the let me see
if i can find the tick tock
but i guess drake was actually like
playing like basketball and like
training with this guy
which that's just really not a nice
thing to do
like that's like that says something
about drake's character if he's willing
to sleep with someone
that has a fiance and like actually
especially if you actually know the guy
um
jake breaks up in there
yeah i can't find the like tick tock but
honestly i don't know the guy's name
but he dodged a bullet if your girl is
willing to cheat on you with the first
like
celebrity that she beats like that's not
someone you want to be
want to be the mother of your children
that's not somebody that you want to
teach like those values under your
daughter
unto your son so he dodged a bullet
that's my two cents i think she fumbled
a bag assuming he was a good boyfriend
and everything that he mentioned you
know
and i will say though eight years if i
dated someone for eight years and i did
not
like i was not married i i would be
upset we would have issues
so let me know in the comments what you
guys think agree
disagree and don't forget to subscribe